la base a confirmé les fragments d'un
satellite ont été découverts au
moyen-orient oh mon dieu
la planète a vu leur nombre augmenter
dans une ampleur sans précédent
tu sais que là bas je te couvrirai c'est
moi qui ai toujours sauver tfs les mecs
photo nous combattrons tous ceux qui
s'opposent à la paix dans ce monde
qu'ils soient humains ou autre chose
pour 28 des monstres offert c'est moi le
chef barrage garde là pour le cas bien
cinq heures on a perdu là comme avec une
unité
trouver nos qu'a été ramenés
ne vous laissez jamais dominé par vos
émotions tu dois rien ressentir tu ne
dis pas tu ne pose pas de questions tu
poursuis ta mission
j'ai un gouffre à
j'ai pas peur des monstres
nous achèverons cette mission